barnegat light
a town on the coast of new jersey had a
reputation
in the 1800s it was the graveyard
of the atlantic it had fast currents
sand bars that shifted and shoals hidden
ridges
that wrecked ships but this narrow
passage was crucial for tons of traffic
from europe
the result was wreck after wreck
after wreck after wreck the lighthouse
was intended
to guide ships away from land it didn't
and a lot of lighthouses around the
world had the same problem
the problem at barnegat was the light
inside that lighthouse
it just wasn't strong enough and the
solution was an
invention that fixed lighthouses from
france to florida
an international upgrade that's still in
use today
and is used in things like this
the lighthouse wasn't enough to save
ships
[Music]
they needed the right lens
i volunteered at the saint augustine
lighthouse here in florida
it was in 1992 so it was a while back
[Music]
and i saw the fresnel lens and it was
just beautiful
and i stood inside of this and i was
surrounded by all these glass prisms
and i was just intrigued by it and i
wanted to know how it worked
my name is dan spinella with artworks
florida classic fresnel lenses
and i'm a lens preservationist and
designer
i build historic reproductions of
classic fresnel lenses and also build
the prisms and lenses to help restore
the original
classic fresno lenses
this is a fresnel lens the breakthrough
that made lighthouses work
like lighthouses should work light from
a lamp is diffuse
too weak for a ship to see it from far
away a fresnel lens fixes that
it takes that light and using prisms
redirects
and magnifies it in one unified
direction
see how this light and this light both
go the same way
a candle becomes a spotlight this is a
fresnel lighthouse with bullseye panels
in the middle
and those look like lights a lot of
people use in lighthouses
and everywhere you know i have a light
fresnel that i attached to my
my little spotlight up here should be
pretty much the same thing right
yes it is it's it's identical in design
and that's what's amazing about it is
something that was designed in 1819
is still being used today i normally
attach this to a light to make a
spotlight
but it is a fresnel when i light a
candle
it takes that light and focuses it into
a spotlight
and so the light gets more intense the
brighter i make it or
in this case the closer i hold it to the
center of the lens
the same thing happens when i use my
phone the fresnel captures
all of that light and focuses and
magnifies it
these lenses weren't just an improvement
they created
a whole system that saved lives
agustin jean fernell an engineer and
physicist
was part of a french lighthouse
commission to improve lighthouses
developed through the 1820s vernell's
lens proved better than existing lights
including the ones at barnegat probably
tens of thousands of wrecks are
scattered throughout the barnegat shoals
and up and down that area of new jersey
uh there were a lot of flaws with that
lighthouse they were called lewis lights
the lewis lamp was successful in so far
it was better than nothing however the
technology was flawed it was
lacking like many lamps at the time a
lewis lamp used a reflector to catch
light
it had a small lens to project that
light but
a lot of light escaped it wasn't bright
enough
so they weren't as efficient and the
metal wasn't as efficient because it
absorbs a lot of the light
that's why the design of the fresnel
lens was so much more efficient that it
collected more of the light
and directed at seaward what it's
supposed to do in addition to
strengthening and magnifying light
fresnel's flashing with rotation turned
them into a communication device
so it creates this flashing
characteristic even though the lamp
is continuously on it was a flame you
couldn't turn it off
depending on how they design the lens it
creates different flashing
characteristics
so you knew where you were at what
location you were at
before gps colored panels or even
colored flames
could make lights more distinct some got
huge
a first order fresnel was this big
more than 75 fresnels are still up and
running today
in the united states alone thanks to
these lenses that rippled across the
globe
lighthouses cast light farther
communicated
more information and saved lives
[Music]
the lighthouse is a wonderfully strange
2019 movie
in which a fresnel is so hypnotic willem
dafoe's character
undresses and bathes in its light the
director called it the cosmic egg
with the production designer dan
spinella made the lens
in the film i had to work a lot of hours
i probably worked 14 16 hour days for
eight weeks straight seven days a week i
didn't take any breaks i got it done
just in time
probably five days before filming i was
creating it up i had to drive it up to
nova scotia from florida
it's sort of a weird showcase for your
work because
it's it's sort of the most flattering
possible look for your work but in a
really
weird movie it's definitely not a
feel-good hallmark movie that's for sure
i mean i i like the fact that the focus
was on the lens
and you didn't i liked the little sneak
peaks of the lens until you got to the
very end of the movie they actually
actually
saw it
it was almost a star in the movie itself
they did a really good job getting
everything historically accurate
the very first lens that i worked on the
saint augustine lighthouse when i
started
designing that lens on the computer i
was just
amazed at how the formulas were actually
working and to think that they did that
in the 1800s and they went to these
formulas and the same thing i was doing
now
crashes still happened at barnegat even
after they added a fourth order for now
the lighthouse was small and the sea was
dangerous
but in 1857 they built a new lighthouse
and it was crucial that they have one
thing in it they got a fresnel lens and
not just a fresnel lens
the biggest one that they built which
was a first order lens
the mariners were very grateful for
because it did save lives because unlike
the lewis light this could shine out at
least 20 miles they really don't know
how far it could shine
because the curvature of the earth but
that's how powerful it is
what they did to rotate the lenses they
used a clockwork mechanism they didn't
have electricity they didn't have
electric motors
they used a clockwork mechanism which is
very similar to a grandfather clock
there's a weight that would drop down
the center of the lighthouse
and that weight was attached to a cable
which was wrapped around a drum
and that drum had a gear on the end of
it and that gear drove a series of gears
inside the clockwork mechanism
and that determined by the ratio of the
gears determined the speed at which the
the lens would rotate it engaged with a
gear that was underneath
the bottom of the lens the lens was on
either chariot wheels ball bearings or
in some cases it was a mercury bath
that allowed it to rotate so that was
built as a demonstration for the
pensacola lighthouse